we're seeing some of this woke ideology
in the US that's creating a lot of
momentum which makes no sense how a
woman who's been a feminist her entire
life to defend women now a man who
identifies as a woman
is able to come and take the freedoms
away from other women who that feminist
once fought for which makes no sense
right so how did you if you were trained
how to convert people into possibly bad
ideas which is what you did at one point
how did you do that how were you so
successful at it how did I uh how did I
convert people to these ideas yes what
did you lean on did you lean on
innocence did you lean on anger did you
lean on rage did you divide yeah what
angles did you take look that's you've
got to understand human psychology
really and what you just said there at
the end of that question is an example
of correct what the approaches you've
got to understand if somebody's angry
then how do you manipulate and weaponize
that anger by steering it now I don't
want to get overly complicated so I'll
give a a more popular example which
everyone will get immediately so we all
imagine watch Star Wars right of course
right so uh the way in which through the
prequels you see Darth Vader become who
Darth Vader becomes and and what happens
to Anakin is an example of what I'm
talking about how you can weaponize and
manipulate anger that comes from Rage
from Love in Anakin's case losing a
loved one right so if you can sympathize
with a human story as it's presented in
Star Wars you can see in real life how
that happens so in a fictional character
who loses a loved one to uh I think
remind me was it a natural death that
Anakin um
um Anakin's lover died of whatever it
was imagine you're in a war zone where
your entire family's been blown up it
becomes incredibly easy to weaponize and
manipulate that anger Isis began in the
in the prisons in Iraq for example uh so
you've got a whole bunch of people whose
country's been invaded and they're
fighting an occupier and they get caught
and they're put into jail and of course
they're angry and that's where that
anger was weaponized again when I say by
the security services in isis's case up
until Isis they were Al-Qaeda Fighters
so I I think it's whether it's anger or
every every emotion every human emotion
can be steered
for the purposes of achieving an outcome
and it was done during covet fear in the
case of covid with covid mandates and
again everything I say please everybody
listening look it up for yourselves
don't believe me when I say things like
uh we we witnessed the uh historically
the largest and most Sinister
psychological operations campaign uh
inflicted upon civilian uh people by
their governments uh during the covert
era this isn't again is no longer in
dispute uh the fact that the whether the
Twitter files have revealed it here in
the uh in the US or to by way of an
example Matt Hancock the health
secretary's WhatsApp messages that were
leaked revealed in the UK where he's
like how do we make the people more
scared yep yep ultimately we which we've
spoken about all of that on the part
that's right and and the 77th Brigade
that I first mentioned on the uh JRE but
mentioned here again is the is a UK
based uh military operations unit called
the the 77th Brigade which on their own
website they state that their purpose is
psychological operations and they were
engaged in this whole covert situation
Twitter was infiltrated by uh operatives
in that way to manipulate our perception
of uh of reality so in the case of covid
they did it with fear in the case of
extremism you do it for example with
anger you could do it with love I mean I
think the Spanish Inquisition was a
manipulation of Love interestingly
enough because the idea you know I will
torture you because it's good for you
and God will redeem you through this and
then when you're seeking Heretics the
idea is you think that you're seeking
Purity and love and of course the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
yeah and but I'm sorry I want to go
deeper in this I want to go deeper you
talk about the Leslie stall video I just
texted you Rob if you want to play this
is 23 seconds from 60 minutes and you
see decisions like this being made this
is in 2001 I may be off but if you can
play it
together we have heard that a half a
million children have died I mean that's
more about children than died when in
Hiroshima and
a thousand incredible you know is the
price worth it I think this is a very
hard choice but the price we think the
price is worth it
okay 1996. did this happen okay if we
can order you all yeah so 1896. that's
another clip you got playing Rob maybe
okay so uh that was the first Iraq yeah
that wasn't 90 that was a second clip
that just to be clear that 1968 yeah I
think so so you know you think about
decisions like that being made okay we
think it was worth it yeah all right you
know uh uh fear covet Was Fear I agree
love you're doing this for God and some
people would say even you know religious
extremists hey you're you know killing
your life you know taking your life and
God's gonna be very happy for you or
Kamikaze right or you know all these
other things that we've all heard about
but I want you to go a little bit deeper
if you can because
you know I I had a girl I hired lady she
wasn't a girl a lady I hired to be one
of my copywriters years ago
and then one day we sit down and two
years later after she's been working
with me and she says you know I got to
tell you why I took this job so tell me
why I took the job well let me take my
background my background is I was one of
those people that bought into a
cult-like leader and I said who and she
mentioned it to me who they called lead
words I said you were part of that
because I was part of that call so what
things happened well we all I as a woman
I was married but we had sex with this
and this and that and she's telling me
as a married woman her husband was okay
that other men of that members what
convinced you of that because I was
convinced we were doing the right thing
and me and my husband all this stuff
typically it comes from a place of
wanted to be part of a community right
this is happening and parents in America
are very worried some of them that can't
afford to send their kids to private
school they have to send their kids to
public school and in public school this
is happening but if you can I want you
to go a little deeper I know you were
doing a Star Wars thing and I know you
kind of you know use that as the analogy
but I want you to actually you know tell
us what it would sound like for example
hey how do you feel about the fact that
such and such is getting all the credit
and you're not right don't you hate it
that you know they don't they don't
really realize you're doing all the work
behind closers without you he would
never be where he's at right now that's
one method right hey did you see what
they did to your family we have to seek
Vengeance we have to go back and do this
right can you actually unpack some of
those recruiting methods yeah so
um you can break an idea down generally
into the political so with the purposes
of extremist recruiting you could break
an idea down into its political
um manifestation it's scriptural uh uh
perspective as well and a rational uh
perspective so let me let me break that
down on the idea of democracy we were uh
we were trained to completely remove the
idea of democracy as having any appeal
to our target audience because clearly
we wanted a theocracy instead now take
the politics it's very easy to do with
democracy actually because it's been
such a sham um even here in America with
Biden and the whole fudge with the
election all of this is coming out the
whole j6 stuff it's all it's all been a
theater but um you know I think it's by
now it's how are people vouch for it how
are people falling for because people
are in their Echo Chambers but let me
just because your question you've asked
it twice let me go into a bit of detail
on that and then clearly we come to the
j6 and all that if you want as well but
um
uh let's take democracy as an idea
um political the political attack from
our proselytizing perspective our
ideological Warfare angle is it easy to
politically attack democracy what I mean
by the political attack is you take this
idea you say right these people claim to
believe in democracy and yet they don't
even adhere to it themselves so for
example is it how uh can you claim that
democracy is what you want for uh the
Arab world when you've just invaded and
occupied a country that's a political
critique of the idea and that would be
easy to do because our actions have
demonstrated that you know the hypocrisy
that
the scriptural references then you know
you again depending on the person you're
speaking if it's a politically active
person you might want to come in with a
political critique first if you're
talking to a religious person who's
traditionally religious and you're I and
your aim is to politicize them because
traditionally devout Muslims weren't
politicized
um and and the faith had always been an
internal uh uh thing but we used to
politicize traditionally develop Muslims
so how would you do that you would take
scripture because that's what they hold
dear as opposed to the political line
and the scriptural references so you
would seek to convince them
that there is a shortcoming or a
misunderstanding in their idea of Islam
and Islam is founded on this key
fundamental point of dohid or the belief
in the Oneness
of the source of the uh of Allah
and so what's saying did in Milestones
the book that you just showed on screen
is to take this idea of heed or Oneness
and demonstrate that you as a Muslim are
falling short of your fundamental
religious obligation to uh to this idea
of one Allah if you allow rival Gods to
be created in the form of these rulers
and then you bring scriptural references
to back that which is actually quite a
revolutionary point which wasn't made in
Islamic discourse before I'd say molduti
he was the founder of jamati Islam in
the Indian subcontinent and molduri was
followed then
by people like said could have been
milestones and and nabahani who was the
founder of Hezbollah the group that I
joined but molduri was one of the first
to make this point the idea that
passages such as in
the Quran which means the Hokum is for
none but Allah now the word Hokum here
could mean uh judgment in the
arbitration sense or it could mean rule
in the theocracy sense yeah as in law
now what the modern day recruiters would
do is take that I did as well you take
that passage and say look see this
the rule is for none but Allah so these
rulers who are ruling with their
man-made uh dictatorial uh laws are
challenging are a direct challenge to
Allah's rule yeah and we have a complete
system of governance that has been
discarded by these dictators who have
become Idols before Allah and shirk or
Idol or polytheism is seen as the the
biggest anathema to dalhir or the
Oneness of Allah right so you can take
somebody down that Journey now the truth
is this passage could not mean what we
were teaching people it meant it's
impossible because the idea of a unitary
legal system imposing one law over all
of society is a modern westphalian
European nation-state idea the idea of
State a state yeah
is a modern idea it doesn't exist in
traditional scripture the word State
Arabic is dollar you will if you were to
take a computer to scan the entire
um uh all Islamic scripture to look for
the word dollar or state you could do it
right now if you want it just doesn't
exist it's not there
the closest you'll get is a word Doula
in the sense of the rotation of money
and and debt but there's no such word as
Dola or for example Navan which means a
system uh or Constitution which means
distort in Arabic right these words are
conspicuous by their absence in
traditional Islamic discourse and that's
not a that's not surprising because they
are very modern political Concepts in
the first place uh and so when we used
to take these words these passages like
to say this means that the rule must be
for none but Allah and the Constitution
therefore must be based on Islam we were
basically imposing very modern uh into
Wars I say interwar European ideas
onto traditional Islamic scripture to
extract from that a political ideology
so that's the scriptural angle that you
could take as opposed to the political
angle then there's the I said the
rational angles to break down the
problem inherent in the idea of
democracy
um and that is an angle to say look you
know when demos Kratz is the idea of the
Greeks the slaves couldn't vote
um who gets to decide uh what you vote
for what you uh what you're even
thinking because if you don't have money
you can't campaign and therefore
democracy really is who gets to be the
biggest billionaire and that this would
be a rational critique of the idea as
opposed to pointing to its hypocrisy uh
the political critique or the scriptural
uh references that I just went through
so you can take any idea and break it
down in those three for the purposes of
recruitment
so how much of it is in the guide that
can give the best argument how much of
it is in the guide that has the money
in the sense of what I'm saying yeah
it's actually more than that it's what
the circumstances are conducive to so if
you if you're taking Rock for example it
was a no-brainer take Afghanistan it's a
no-brainer that the um the jihadists are
going to win the argument there I'm not
going to win an argument if you've got
occupation forces yeah in the it's just
it's I can be a everything I'm saying
today may sound really nice and smart it
doesn't matter During the covid period I
was saying this at the the anti-covered
stuff I was saying it on air to I mean
it was a huge audience
um on the largest commercial radio
platform in the UK and my show was on a
weekend Lunchtime with over half a
million listeners when people should be
out having their weekend brunches
and it it didn't land why because when
people are scared they're not looking I
mean instead I got sacked right
um I mean it landed in the sense like
obviously the argument in the end won I
think we won that argument in the end
and even if people haven't realized it
yet I think they will eventually but at
the time it didn't change government it
didn't change politicians thinking it
didn't change the people that needed to
be influenced by that argument weren't
listening because they were scared
if you're in under occupation you're not
going to listen to the majids or the my
brothers that work with me on this kind
of stuff because that if you're under
occupation you're angry so those
emotions whether it's fear whether it's
anger even love which can blind if if
the con if the conditions aren't
conducive to what I'm saying which is
why I'm saying that the China negotiated
peace between Iran and Saudi or the
Abraham Accords this will all calm the
situation down in the Middle East and we
need a calmer situation to be able to
have these kinds of conversations so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you